they're putting somebody to sleep right
now for me to operate on okay so I have
to call would you like me to call them
and tell them a Florida plastic surgeon
arrested for possession of meth while
he's on his way to work to operate on a
patient um they're all waiting for me
right now the arrest happened on May
24th 2022 when officers pulled over Dr
William Wright Adams for a traffic stop
in pinelis County Florida according to
the criminal complaint the traffic stop
was initiated to question Dr Adams about
a 2021 residential
burglary they're lighting him
up looks like he just pulled over on 3st
Street perfect we can 15 him right
[Music]
away when the officer approaches the
doctor's vehicle police immediately
Place him in cup Dr Adams then tells the
officers he's on his way to the
operating room for a patient who's about
to undergo
surgery I'll explain everything
okay what's going on I'll explain
everything all right supposed to okay
that's fine this is more important right
now all
right is this too tight to pull your
hands second
set operating where
at you operating where at
you okay where at my office where's
that you got anything in your pockets or
anything I don't think so I'll check
I'll check authorities then Place him in
the backseat of the police squad car
then proceeds to search Dr Adams's
vehicle his cell phone's right there his
back
there yeah I want to
grab
that
place I saw him picking it up while we
were um following him
too shortly after the officer pulls a
backpack from Adams's car but when the
officer officer goes to speak to Adams
the Florida doctor urges the officer
that his patient is waiting for him we
want somebody to come and pick up your
car cuz we're parked on 31
street right busy
street I'm not sure what's going on okay
well I'd love to talk to you um before I
can ask you anything got to read you
your rights okay but I want to figure
out because we're blocking a busy street
right here they're putting somebody to
sleep right now for me to operate on
okay so I have to call would you like me
to call
and tell them or are they going to do
that when you show
up um they're all waiting for me right
now okay so are they doing the medicine
prior to you showing
up station probably some usually yes yes
or no cuz I'll make a call over there
please call police then make a call to
Dr Adams's office to let his staff know
not to put the patient under anesthesia
and to have someone from the office pick
up his vehicle just tell him not to uh
sedate the next uh person is there
somebody that can pick up your car or
are we just going to tow it yes there is
okay who is it um just if just tell them
you if someone need to come pick up the
car they'll do that there's more than
enough people are you saying from
someone from the office yeah there's
more than enough he's saying there's
more than enough people at the office to
come and pick up the car the officer
then attempts to question Dr Adams but
he refuses and asks for a lawyer I know
you probably have uh no clue what's
going on right now but I think you have
a uh perspective of what I'm going to
bring up that I appreciate um statements
for um that's up to you um I want to ask
you specific questions but before I do
that I had to read you your rights um
okay we do that with everyone that's in
custody okay okay all right
um you have the right to remain silent
anything you say you can would be used
against you in a court of law you have
the right to talk to a lawyer and have
him or her present with you while you
being questioned you cannot afford to
hire a lawyer one will be appointed to
represent you you could decide at any
time to exercise these rights and not
answer any questions or make any
statements do you understand each of
these rights I have explained to you yes
sir having these rights in mind do you
wish to talk to me now I would my
attorney Kevin Hayler okay you want your
attorney present yes sir okay while
police wait to hear back from Adams's
lawyer they continue searching inside
the doctor's backpack where the officer
locates a glass pipe and later small
bags containing crystal meth after the
officers bag up their evidence then
authorities are eventually able to get
in touch with the doctor's lawyer who
tells his client to hang tight we're
going to invoke your rights against
self-incrimination this is not the time
to tell your story there will be a time
this is not that time so I have invoked
your rights uh uh again speaking to them
uh we'll have an opportunity to speak to
the right people at the right time just
today is not the time so I'm going to
ask you not to answer any more of the
questions they're not going to ask you
any more questions I would ask Bill that
you don't
voluntarily want to explain what
happened because there'll be a time for
that do you understand that Bill yes sir
okay so let's just let's assume that
you've been given propop fall and you
can't talk okay so just say nothing
let's go ahe and just uh we'll I'll
connect with you I will get you bonded
out of jail this afternoon it will take
probably till 3 or 4:00 today they've
got to book you they're going to take
you this process takes some
time so um after you get out you and I
will talk okay yes sir okay and then at
at the appropriate time we will talk to
the people that need to hear your story
okay yes sir according to the arrest
report a codefendant told authorities
Adams hired him to rob an ex-boyfriend's
home and retrieve property Adams said
was gifted to him the report goes on a
State security surveillance video
captured what looked to be Adams's
vehicle driving by the victim's home and
two neighbors spotted a man in teal
scrubs and a person in a cowboy hat
court records show Adams was later
charged with possession of
methamphetamine and drug paraphernalia
as well as residential burglary he is
slated to go on trial for the charges in
December according to reports this
wasn't Dr Adams's first running with the
law he was arrested in 2020 for
possession of meth but prosecutors later
dropped those charges the Florida
Department of Health license
verification website also shows Dr
Adams's license is clear and active with
no record of complaints or discipline
despite his arrest but the doctor
reportedly took to his social media that
he plans to retire from his practice
effective December 1st reporting for
long crime Network I'm Elizabeth
Milner I'm Anette Levy and I'm I'm here
to tell you about crime fix a new show
right here on Law and crime crime fix is
a daily YouTube show and podcast
covering the most gripping trending true
crime stories of the day 5 days a week a
criminal complaint was filed charging
the defendant Mr Colberg with four
counts for scree murder crime fix is
quick it's accurate and unbiased we are
here today to announce the arrest of
60-year-old Dwayne Keith Davis aka Kei D
for the murder of Tupac Shakur we give
you the facts and what's really
happening in the world of crime in a way
that only a law and crime show can I
would never hurt my wife Maggie and I
would never hurt my son paa you can
watch crime fixed beginning November
13th on Law and crimes YouTube channel
at 6 p.m. Eastern Monday through Friday
and you can listen anytime wherever you
get your favorite podcasts I'll say Alec
is entitled to any trial and he will get
a n trial join us you won't regret it